- Well, compared to
your sister's c-section,
how was the puppy's birth?
'cause, I had one of my dogs, Chelsea.
She was a mommy to a huge
litter, and it all happened
on my bed and there was
just blood everywhere.
It was like a massacre.
She ruined everything and we were poor.
So it's not like we could just run
out to Bed, Bath and Beyond.
- You're just like washing it
and now everything's pink.
- I'm like, yeah.
Was it it a massacre?
Was it?
- No, actually.
= Oh, come on. What is it?
- I was ready.
I had the pantry set up
and I had my playlist,
and Liddy and I spent hours
together listening to music.
- I love you.
- And then I didn't know
this, and I don't know,
this is, listen.
There's a way to find out.
You can just look it up online
but I didn't really know
how puppies were born.
But hers came out in little pods.
Did yours come out in little pods?
Is that normal?
- I don't remember.
I literally walked in,
I just saw blood everywhere.
I think she just was kind
of, I wasn't in the room.
I don't know if I'd come home from school.
It was so long ago,
but I just remember my bed looking like...
- Yeah
- Someone did that. Yeah yeah. Yeah.
- Well, she was very graceful about it.
We just have one little pod
and then do some stuff until
the baby came outta the pod.
- So crazy.
- It was.
- And then how do you know when it's done?
- You're like,
- You don't.
- Are there more coming?
Yeah. That's crazy.
- Two o'clock in the morning.
I'm like Lidy.
I love you.
You got this.
I've gotta go to sleep.
- Nature.
- It could be.
- You're gonna make it.
- Yeah. And she did.
Yeah. She had eight.
- Eight.
- That's a lot of puppies.
- Oh my gosh.
Did you finally find a home for them all,
or do you still have some?
- Oh my gosh. I found a home for them all.
- That's, that's amazing.
- Yeah. My brother has one of them.
- Okay. You're just like calling people.
Take it.
- Yes.
I am like take the dogs.
- It's gonna be awesome.
Does Larry also have a thing
with making sure everyone
has fresh breath on set?
I've found this out, which I appreciate.
- Yeah.
- It's very fresh on our set.
- People don't get this
because it's like, even
if microphones with singers,
you'll do like a radio show
and you'll get some mic
and you'll be like, what?
- No.
- Yeah.
- That's not cute.
- So people will be on set
and your doing kissing scenes.
- Right.
So everybody's very close to everybody.
So Larry has a lot of
peppermint oil, but I will,
this is some advice that
I'm gonna give to everybody.
- Okay.
- If anyone ever offers
you a mint, take it.
- You have halitosis.
- Yeah.
Don't ask just say thank-you.
- Thank you.
- Don't go oh why?
- Be in a polite way.
- Yeah.
- You don't need to have
a dialogue. Just take it.
Say thank you.
- That's amazing advice.
So wait, I'm thinking of all the times
if anybody has ever done that.
- I know.
- Anyway, so you visited your
old improv acting class recently.
So what was that like?
- So I came up at the
Groundlings Theater, on Melrose.
- Cool. Yeah.
- So fun.
It was sketch comedy and improv.
And I just went back and did
an improv show with them.
And they're so. the actors there
are amazing and they're great improvisers,
and I'm, I'm not used to being
on stage improvising.
I'm used to being on television.
It's just different.
You don't have an audience
watching you like ah.
- Yeah.
- You know, I'm up there like, oh my god,
lower your expectations.
- Lower the bar
- Please. That should
be your comedy special
- Should be right.
- Yeah. Lower the bar.
- Lower the bar.
- But they're so a game
and up for anything
in an improv, you have
to say yes to everything
that anybody throws out.
So I found myself, on a Friday night
doing an improv about these two, trying to
save the world against
demon babies and mermaids
- And mermaids.
- So I was a baby crawling
around on the Grounding
stage at 10 o'clock
on a Friday night going,
oh, it's been a while.
- Demon babies and mermaids.
- Yes. Does someone just
pull that out of a hat?
- Well, they take it from the audience.
- I want to watch this.
I've never seen anything like this.
- Oh my gosh.
You've gotta go.
- Yeah. I've never seen.
- It's pretty amazing.
- Okay.
- Yeah, so the actors are
up there and they say,
"Where are these two people"?
- It's hysterical.
- They're in a film.
What's the name of the film?
Demon Mermaids and Babies.
- And go,
- That's exactly what happened.
- Oh my god.
- That's exactly how it works.
- That sounds fun,
especially with alcohol.
- it's really fun.
- I'll call. Are there any
sketches that you still remember
from when you were starting out?
- Oh, well I did this.
I did this scene with my
friend Shane Nickerson
and we were supposed to be rapping
at a middle school because
the rappers didn't show up.
So we stepped in and rapped
to Intergalactic Planetarium.
- Yeah.
- Plantarium intergalactic.
- Oh just feel free.
- Thank-you.
During the show I forgot the words.
- Oh, that happens
every show for me.
- So I just started scatting.
Oh that happens every
show we'll go, go. go.
- Do bop a doo dat dat.
And then my scene partner was like,
is that what we're doing?
Okay. Skid op da do do.
There were just these
two weird people dressed
as teachers, scatting and
then the lights go out.
- Oh my God, it's amazing.
This one time in a show,
you can edit this out.
I literally, I think I was in like,
I don't know, Amsterdam, somewhere
in Europe or something
and I forgot the lyrics to this song.
And what's funny about the
bridge is it's an octave jump
with the same lyrics.
And so it literally went from,,,
(non intelligible singing)
- It would just went an Octave higher
of me just still not.
I was like, nope didn't come.
- Then you gave your all.
But you just have to, you
just have to give it your all
- You know what?
And my eyes, I was like, that's right.
That's right.
- That's what you have to do.
- That's what you're here for.
- Yeah.
A hundred percent. got that.
You love this, I'm making
it special for you.